[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo on va refaire toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine bonjour katia bonjour
michael et cette semaine nous
accueillons bernard debré bonjour
bonjour est député à l'ère de la 4e
circonscription paris conseiller de
paris et conseiller stratégique de
françois fillon fillonniste de la
première heure même on va revoir avec
vous l'actualité riche de cette semaine
avec un grand débat à onze candidats qui
a été marquée par quelques échanges
piquant on va leur a aussi de la
campagne d' emmanuel macron qui est en
marche et en quête de candidats aussi
pour les élections législatives
et puis celle de françois fillon
déterminé à maintenir le cap malgré la
tourmente
ban à deux voix si vous permettez on va
commencer par l'actualité internationale
et les frappes américaines contre
l'armée syrienne qui ont lieu dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi
ç'a eu lieu d'une décision unilatérale
de donald trump souvent entre des
représailles à la taxe unique
est-ce que donald trump à bien faire
selon je suis très très ambigu dans ce
domaine là bien sûr je n'aime pas du
tout bachar al assad et il faudra un
jour qu'il s'en aille qu'il s'en aille
véritablement tout est même qu'il soit
traduit devant une cour pénale
internationale ravoet et si on laissait
ses meurtriers comme ça en duo pro tools
utiliser du gaz destruction massive et
cetera dans la nature c'est pas pour
qu'au pénal international atteler cour
pénale internationale met en avant pour
ça je dis que je suis ambiguë par
rapport à l'action américaine conduite
sans résolution l'onu justement si les
américains qui sont devenus totalement
imprévisible tirs des 59 missiles
tomahawk comme ça mais mais mais ils ont
prévenu avant à dire qu'ils n'ont pas
abîmer de d'avion ils ont prévenu les
russes qui ont prévenu les syriens donc
yaya quatre ou six morts c'est terrible
pour ces man on va quand on envoie 59
missiles tomahwak qu il n'y a pas de
d'avion d'abîmer ni eau ni beaucoup de
morts c'est tout le monde a été prévenue
alors c'est peut-être ça qui est
intéressant oui on prévient et ont
appréhendé un monsieur machin à 7 vous
ne ferez plus ça mais après
après faudra qu'on ouvre des
négociations mais après faudra aussi
qu'on continue à lutter contre d'âge
parce que ça complique pas les choses
vont bien sûr xanax duc les choses c'est
de la faute à un brutal de monsieur
trump ça complique les choses
il ya une coalition d'abord avec les
américains nous les anglais et s'est
appuyé à une coalition qui de l'autre
côté avec les russes il fallait au moins
que ces deux coalitions se mettent
d'accord pour aller combattre des
chenaux principal ennemi c'est quand
même des ch
c'est celui qui vient chez nous qui tue
qui met des bombes en europe aux etats
unis en russie
bon il fait le rap sont elles utiles
donc pour lutter contre l' échoue à
balancer vos montres et la merce puisque
vous avez l'opposition syrienne qui est
quand même une école en visite que cette
ses frappes là sont inutiles non parce
que l on monterait à monsieur machin à 7
qui ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi et
on donnait 1,10 un coup de pied dans la
fourmilière maintenant et j'espère qu'il
y aura des négociations alors éminente
justement la syrie est devenue s'est
invitée dans la campagne présidentielle
française je vous propose de réécouter
ce que disait ce jeudi françois fillon à
propos de la syrie
je ne crois pas que cette formule là
celle d'une intervention militaire
occidentale en syrie soit la bonne donc
il reste une deuxième solution qui est
celle que je prône depuis toujours qui
consiste à parler même si c'est
difficile avec les russes avec les
iraniens avec les turcs pour essayer de
trouver un accord qui ménage les
intérêts des uns et des autres de ce que
je viens de citer et qui permettent le
départ de bachar el-assad et l'évolution
du régime syrien
voilà pour la position de françois
fillon qui s'exprimait juste avant que
ces frappes ne soit décidée je vous
propose d'écouter également ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron sur le même sujet une
intervention militaire comme vous le
savez il y à une coalition de plus de
soixante états qui aujourd'hui est
impliqué sur le terrain contre des shu
aujourd'hui principe d'une intervention
militaire contre bachar également contre
dèche donc aujourd'hui si ces faits sont
confirmés il est indispensable en effet
d'agir fortement vous dites que le même
coalition doit se retourner contre
bachar est de le faire dans le cadre
d'un mandat de l'onu
françois fillon emmanuel macron n'ont
pas la même position
non d'abord françois fillon l'avait vu
que nous avons la même position
du moins je suis français fuyant ce
domaine là c'est tombe bien c'est
évident qu'il faut maintenant faire une
grande coalition pour combattre des ch
et une fois qu'on aura gagné
est ce qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas loin
de gagner des chais est encerclée et
l'intervention militaire dit emmanuel
macron il a dit au début il n'a pas dit
à la fin à la lave noire ah oui c'est
stupide parce que si vous avez compris
ce qu'elle dit emmanuel macron vous
n'oubliez quand même pas qu'à la fin il
dit non non pas des adaptations
militaire mais je dis que c'est
complètement stupide c'est
incompréhensible
d'ailleurs on a vu dans tout au long de
du discours des manuels macondé de
l'émission diane j'ai rien compris
enfin pardonnez moi ce fut peut-être
partisans bon s'il devient président oui
ça m'inquiète parce que là il est il a
commencé par dire on va faire une
opération militaire
oui mais après à la fin et dit non c'est
pas une opération militaire
on n'envoie pas de troupes mais une
opération militaire sans voix elle
troupes ni d'avions jeu pas comment ça
peut se passer il dit on va aller punir
bastad
et puis après on le prend pour une
négociation c'était absolument
incompréhensible et à poutine et vous
inquiéterait vous avez déjà nous
actuellement aujourd'hui face à trump
impôts t'aimons n'existe pas vous ne
savez bien
donc j'espère que si françois fillon est
élu il aura plus de charisme et de
volonté face à tremper à poutine mais
pas emmanuel macron un gamin qui ne
connaît rien aux gamins qui me connaît
rien s'est il est candidat à l'élection
présidentielle oui les capacités il ya
jean yves le drian d'ailleurs lu par
exemple ah oui je crois qu'il prenait
pas de d'anciens présidents concernés
qu'il a besoin de ces cautions notamment
sur ces questions
ce qu'il a dit hier il ne connaît
strictement rien à rien jouer mais
reprenez au lieu de reprendre toute
petite phrase n'est pas reprenez ce
qu'il a dit au début à la fin c'est
extra venir celle inverse on attaque on
y va on envoie des troupes et à la fin
le nom bien sûr on n'en voit pas trop
peu ans commence à ouvrir une
négociation penser que ces hésitations
pour être dangereux
cl oui tout à fait oui mais surtout sur
notre dame des landes
pardonnez moi de revenir là dessus mais
vous avez compris on s'écarte un petit
peu du dossier oui bah lula là et
c'était la deuxième question qu'on lui a
posé j'ai rien compris mais rien rien il
met un négociateur au milieu vous avez
du temps sur le manuel macro cornalin
pas là on était sur la syrie on va
bouffer la floride au nord je dis
simplement attention voilà attention à
l'onu parce que si on s'amuse
si on s'amuse pardonnez moi d'utiliser
ce terme c'est inapproprié si on décide
d'attaquer sans avoir prévenu sans avoir
l'aval de la venue un peu dangereux
allez on revient maintenant sur
l'actualité politique on va dérouler
tout de suite et voient s'intéressait
notamment au débat qui a eu lieu ce
débat avec onze candidats à l'élection
présidentielle revue des passes d'armes
qui ont marqué ceux des bals auront rien
juste après je n'ai pas trahi mes idéaux
le j'ai refusé sérénité et je ne les ai
pas signé qui ont abaissé la france
pouvoir pour le faire
je n'aurais jamais signé et je ne
l'aurais prochaine fois non plus et je
me suis battu prenez garde à ce que
décideront les français savaient pas ce
qu'ils vont décider les français
allaient sont évidemment très attachés à
leurs traditions il veut les conserver
et bien grâce à cette révision constitue
notre île soit 100 landes faits n'ont
pas de religion
fichez nous la paix avec un religion ne
sommes pas obligés de subir vos foucades
vos trouvailles
c'est une manière de nous imposer à tous
et l'arrière de vivre qui les mettrait
d'accord avec vous sur ce dernier point
vous êtes toujours d'accord avec tout le
moment ce n'est pas vrai ça manque de
solutions votre programme sur leur page
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça finira
au plan b c'est ma conviction au plan à
ma conviction aujourd'hui que c'est que
le chemin que vous proposez c'est la
sortie de l'euro et de l'europe
jacques séminal avait le droit mais
c'est beaucoup
alors lisez moi je regarde ouf j'ai
envie de vous dire ouf c'était attendu
avec impatience on disait c'est une
première on va écouter on va avoir une
confrontation à 11 4 heures et qu'elle
que c'était difficile
un peu de cacophonie à françois fillon
effacés non non ils ont retravaillé plus
en retrait mais attendez c'était
difficile à écouter à suivre c'était un
peu d'ici et d'ailleurs étaient
tellement vin qu'il n'ya pas le 20 avril
de deuxième émission de ce type
onze personnes pendant quatre heures
vous êtes content qu'ils aient pas de
deuxième débat de ce type la trouvais
que c'était quand même très difficile à
écouter
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
ont besoin on a envie de vous d'avoir ce
genre de débat ou pas que ça peut les
aider à mes débuts
et bien sûr ça doit exister mais il faut
trouver une autre solution peut-être
faire par 3 par quatre tirés au sort qui
va être dans cette émission pour faire
plusieurs émissions mais là c'était
franchement très in écoute alors y'a
quand même des petits moments marquants
et notamment les petits candidats qui
ont donné de la voix à l'image de
philippe poutou qui a interpellé marine
le pen et françois fillon ont écouté et
là depuis janvier or là c'est le régal
une campagne super fillon voilà il est
en face de moi que des histoires et plus
aux fouilles plus plus on sent la
corruption plus on sent la triche et à
côté de ça donc
en plus c'est des bonhommes qui nous
explique qu'il faut la rigueur qu'il
faut l'austérité et eux mêmes ils
piquent dans les caisses publiques donc
il ya comme ça oui dans la mesure où il
va merci donc bon c'est ce que j'ai dit
je les dis ensuite à aussi le pen à côté
alors va peut-être réagir aussi mais le
pain de pareilles on pique dans les
caisses publiques
là c'est pas c'est pas ici c'est
l'europe alors l'europe pour quelqu'un
qui est anti européens se souviennent
pas de piquer de l'argent de l'europe
et le pire c'est qu'en plus le fn qui se
dit anti système
le centenaire de pas du tout se
protègent grâce aux lois du système
grâce à l'immunité parlementaire et donc
ne refuse d'aller au convocation
policière donc peinard donc là tout ça
ça illustre ce coup là c'est pour la
police ça ça illustre ouais quand nous
les convoqués par la police nous vous
voyez par exemple on a pas d'immunité
ouvrière désolé on y va voilà vous avez
une chance
[Applaudissements]
jean louis debré à l'issue de ce débat
françois fillon bernard de bernard debré
pardon pardon pardon françois fillon a
menacé de un procès à philippe
poutou
oui m est ce que vous vous rendez compte
qu'il a dit c'est justifié il a ou des
mois je m'attendais deçà philippe poutou
est un homme qui est quand même très
très agressif d'une agressivité décuplée
parce qu'il sait qu'il fera 0 1% ou 0 5%
donc il va il va accuser tout le monde
mais c'est extrêmement grave ces
accusations présomption d'innocence de
bordeaux il n'a jamais été accusé
d'avoir piqué dans la caisse et je
dirais c'est comme un ça fout ça fait sa
rentrée mal à l'aise mais ça foutrait
mal à l'aise pour utiliser les termes je
m'attendais pas à autre chose de
monsieur moutons que ça a ajouté sophie
les premières puces ajouté
voilà je me demande comment il a eu ses
500 signatures tant mieux pour lui ça
fait deuxième ou troisième fois qu'ils
se présentent il fait 0 5 d'ailleurs il
sait très bien qu'il ne sera pas élu il
vient pour dire des insanités il les dit
très bien vous avez retenu autre chose
de philippoteaux je vous parle
maintenant des manuels macro 5 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est à moins de dix semaines des
élections législatives et le mouvement
en marche
tank de désigner des candidats pour
cette élection 14 mille adhérents du
mouvement en marche ont entrepris les
démarches pour espérer être candidats
envoient le reportage d'arnaud richard
qui les a suivis séance de tractage à
neuilly-sur-seine pour le candidat
macron sur le thème du renouveau
démocratique
pas de quoi décourager ses militants ils
sont étudiants fonctionnaires ou cadres
dans le privé des marcheurs qui demain
se verrait bien s'asseoir dans
l'hémicycle du palais bourbon
si on retenait nos candidatures pour les
législatives ce sera un immense pas en
avant je prends grand spi pour le
renouvellement du personnel politique
parce que nous ne sommes pas nous ne
sommes pas des politiques n'ont pas
d'expérience politique
comme eux ils sont quatorze mille à
s'être inscrits sur internet parmi
lesquels 35 % de femmes
l'ancien ministre de l'économie veut la
parité et des visages neuf dans au moins
la moitié des 577 circonscriptions il y
a deux semaines il a précisé son
calendrier sur notre antenne je n'exclus
pas de proposer en tout cas une première
vague d'investiture avant les élections
présidentielles il y aura des
investitures dans les semaines qui
suivront le premier tour et tout cela
sera finalisée après le deuxième tour
des candidats qui une fois désignés vont
devoir mener une campagne express du
côté d' en marche
on compte sur le souffle d'une victoire
à la présidentielle pour avoir une
majorité
on est très confiant que si on passe le
deuxième tour si on arrive à gagner et
bien derrière les français nous
accompagneront sur les législatives et
donneront à emmanuel macron une majorité
présidentielle qui lui permettra de
réformer en profondeur la france en
marche ne reçoit pour l'instant pas de
fonds publics
une fois désigné les candidats devront
donc avancer leurs frais de campagne
on m'a beaucoup parlé bernard degré d
des questions de ralliement vous avez
été chiraquien non j'étais balladuriens
pas naturel est ce que j'aime beaucoup
je veux vous avez vu qu'il ya de
nombreux chiraquiens qui qui le
rejoignent aujourd'hui ça vous surprend
pas faire à lille
devrais je me fais remarquer que jacques
chirac avait appelé à voter pour
françois hollande et que mon frère
jumeau qui est un chiraquien historique
a fait la même chose à l'époque a appelé
à voter françois hollande
donc c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui
est en train de se passer peut-être dur
et des wc avec une personne absolument
inconnu qui sont là non non non il ya un
déchirement et un déchirement du parti
socialiste et à un effondrement du parti
socialiste et ça va être
d'un côté l'extrême gauche qui va être
présentée par un mélenchon et la gauche
ça va être présentée par macron voilà
mais quant à ses candidats virtuels pour
l'instant c'est virtuel c'est la
fondation à plateaux télé savoir combien
quelques voiliers quelques-uns et à 1
577 anormalement vous parlez de edouard
balladur est ce que vous trouvez qu
emmanuel macron traverse un peu là la
même zone de turbulence qu'avait connu
edouard balladur à l'époque certains
même à droite disent qu'ils se baladent
du rize t oui parce que j'ai
l'impression que quand on plus on les
écoute plus on s'aperçoit que c'est un
peu vide incantatoire hier c'était
particulier la vallée cette nouveauté
allez avoir des candidats internet mais
il sait pas ce que c'est que la police
ne peut pas marcher en france a enfin
nulle part vous êtes candidat vous
faites une campagne électorale il faut
être dans les rues et une campagne de
terreur vous allez voir les gens il faut
être connu les que qu'on le veuille ou
non on va voir là on va voir les gens
qui qui qui vous regardent qui vous
connaissent qui vous apprécie tout d'un
coup on va avoir des zombies qui vont
arriver
après les élections il ya six semaines
comment est ce qu'ils vont faire
on ne sait pas encore qui sait c'est
complètement psychédélique complètement
psychédélique
j'espère qu'il y aura d un
renouvellement mais il y aura un
renouvellement puisque ghana et à au
moins 150 ou 200 députés qui ne se
représente pas dont vous et moi j'ai
donné ma place j'ai donné ma place j'ai
demandé l'investiture pour une femme
beaucoup plus jeune qui a de
l'expérience qui est maire
17e une nouvelle assemblée meilleur
règne nouvelle assemblée
parce qu'il n'ya plus de cumul ce qui
n'est pas une mauvaise chose
donc il ya beaucoup de françois fillon
ne reviendra pas sur cette mesure
il a dit noter entériné comme il l'a dit
c'est une bonne chose
entendons-nous bien je pense qu'on ne
peut pas cumuler président de région va
cumuler près maire d'une grande ville a
peut-être pour les petites villes ont
garé met donc un renouvellement des jeux
tirés par au sort sur internet
on est totalement psychédélique lorsque
bernard debré on va parler maintenant un
peu plus en détails de la campagne de
françois fillon françois fillon qui
était en meeting ce jeudi à strasbourg
journée mouvementée pour le candidat de
la droite qui a exposé sa vision de
l'europe tout en attaquant quelque peu
emmanuel macron pas de casseroles pas
deux mais de la farine alors qu'ils font
la foule françois fillon reçoit un sac
de farine sur la tête les en farine
heures vite évacuer s'était glissé parmi
les jeunes militants fillonniste
quelques minutes plus tard l'ancien
premier ministre réapparaît plus
déterminé que jamais je suis pas venu ce
soir à strasbourg pour vous parler de
boulangerie je suis venu pour vous
parler de culture dans un discours assez
différent de ses précédents meetings
françois fillon défend longuement la
langue et la culture françaises
l'histoire est aussi l'idée d'un récit
national et il vise bien sûr son
adversaire préféré
on n'ose plus prononcé les mots nation
patrie racines culture ce qui devrait
être les plus beaux mots de la langue
française sont devenus des mots qu'on
prononce à voix basse on est prié de se
faire discret comment est-ce qu'on en
est arrivé là
par quelles faiblesses de l'esprit
peut-on en arriver à dire je ne connais
pas d'art français où il n'ya pas de
culture française
quel
quel somnifères idéologique peut bien
aveugle et monsieur macron lorsqu'il lit
des choses pareilles le candidat se
lance dans un long plaidoyer pour
l'europe et un partenariat renforcé avec
l'allemagne plus un mot des affaires il
laisse ses soutiens reprendre les
accusations pour dénoncer un cabinet
noir à l'elysée
vous pouvez l'appeler cabinet noir
cabinet rose cabinet violer ce que vous
voulez c'est de toute manière une
machination c'est ça c'est une
machination et une manipulation qui a
été orchestré en utilisant les les
compétences qui sont les siennes et le
pouvoir qui est le sien
d'instrumentaliser les services de
l'état et tous à un moment ça sera
démontée jusqu'au bout françois fillon
entretient la flamme de ses supporters
un dernier salut avant le départ un
geste rare pour fillon l'introverti un
geste en forme de baroud d'honneur à
moins de trois semaines du premier tour
bernard debré françois fillon a promis
de poursuivre ce qu'ils désignent comme
la responsable de ses ennuis judiciaires
à commencer par françois hollande est ce
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout ce qu'il en a
les moyens
jamais entendu ça va aller il ya quand
même quelque chose qu'il faut faire
remarquer qu'il faut remarquer quand
vous regardez par exemple celle héritée
du parc naturel financier formidable
mais monsieur béroud j'avais lu le livre
de corinne lepage
quand ils lepage dire maintenant mais
attendez moi quand j'ai été élue au
parlement européen on a reçu une lettre
de monsieur berrou nous disons
d'employés d'embauché sont ses
secrétaires à paris et de les payer sur
l'europe les frais européens est madame
corinne lepage dit moi j'ai pas voulu le
faire mais marielle de sarnez l'a fait
puisque la secrétaire de monsieur berrou
à paris étaient payés par leur arc et
nationales financées qui a décidé de ne
pas enquêter sur les soupçons de cabinet
noir ça vous surprend pas à pas du tout
pas du tout quand on sait qu'il est très
très orienté évidemment mais y'a machine
c'est la politique
la chine assure politique vous avez
tourné cet argent
vu que tous les présidents de la
république avaient à leur disposition
moi ce que je regrette c'est que onze
journées sainte nitouche
regardez par exemple les fuites la levée
du secret d'instruction
françois fillon est auditionné c'est une
heure après dans les journaux monsieur
leroux est auditionné vous avez vu que
c'était dans les journaux il a
démissionné 24 heures mais après il a
été auditionné par les juger par la
police y'a rien qui n'ait sorti cet
extraordinaire ya deux poids deux
mesures pourquoi comment est-ce que ça
sort parce que quand on est ambitieux né
il ya une note qui passe au procureur
qui est donnée à au ministre de la
justice c'est l'article 39 1 du code de
procédure pénale c'est obligatoire et ça
va vers le prêt un public qui en fait ce
qu'il veut qui peut elle a redonné le
fait que ce sens il a fait le parquet
national financier qui du coup ne va pas
l'entente et sur ce que vous demandiez
vous voyez quoi alors sais pas quand
mais quand on regarde le patrimoine de
monsieur macro diallo lorient n'y a rien
à regarder alors que beaucoup de gens se
posent des questions
quand on dit mais tu es folle a
peut-être prendre quand même enquêté
pourquoi parce que pannon pécresse elle
en a subi les conséquences quand son
fils a été pris avec trois grammes de
cannabis s'était tout de suite dans les
journaux pourquoi pas se veut dire
simplement qu'il ya une volonté de
françois fillon de nuire à la droite
on le sait très bien mais est-ce que de
françois hollande de françois anglade 6
françois hollande
en somme ils s'appellent tous françois
françois mitterrand tous qu'il a les
moyens d'aller jusqu'au bout des litiges
je demanderai des comptes
il a des problèmes les moyens il
travaille actuellement président de la
république avant et après de tal nof que
le problème c'est qu'il faudra porter
plainte contre ses adjoints ne peut pas
porter plainte contre lui dans
l'exercice de son pouvoir
même après il est protégé mais enfin
écoutez il ya quand même des indices
graves et concordants
moi je veux juste savoir sur le dernier
geste qu'on a vu dans le reportage
françois fillon qui montrent presque sur
le sa voiture et qu'il aime le point
rarissime de le voir à ce point là est
ce que vous estimez qu'il se passe
quelque chose pour françois fillon vous
estimez que aller entre guillemets ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui à la mode
l'art au monde dadaab est possible
ajouté moi je vais vous dire ce que je
ressens je vais dans toutes les villes
quasiment tous les soirs jean-yves de
langon et avait 4 à 500 personnes
je n'ai jamais vu ça pour moi pas pour
moi pour françois fillon
j'ai développé le programme santé et ces
sondages se trompent selon mais non pas
du tout je n'en sais rien d'avortements
sont toujours trompés
moi je me souviens de trois semaines ou
quinze jours avant les élections à la
primaire on le nomme enfin gelé pour
soutenir fillon quand même il va arriver
troisième peut-être 4e et vu ce qui
s'est passé alors je ne dis pas que
c'est la même chose et tout autant
composition que tout est possible et
qu'on est en train de remonter je
l'espère allez on passe à notre
partenaire du figaro qui est avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour jim jean michel basquiat bonjour
bernard debré au sujet des accusations
de cabinet noir dont on vient de parler
on a appris cette semaine que des
conseillers de l'elysée avait été visée
par des menaces de mort on a aussi vu
des journalistes qui ont été bousculés
dans les meetings est ce que vous pensez
pas que les accusations qui ont été
portées justement peuvent favoriser ces
comportements arrêté deux minutes qui
n'a pas reçues et moi j'ai reçu des
dizaines de menaces de mort je me
souviens quand j'avais fait une lettre
ouverte contre strauss kahn je n'avais
reçu 20 menaces de mort bon si vous avez
des déséquilibres est partout et c'est
pas parce qu'on dit la vérité qu'il y
aura des menaces de mort on n'a pas de
dire attention on sait qu' il y a eu des
fuites on sait que tout l'elysée
distribue à tout le monde
des informations qui devraient
normalement ne pas être du ce mais je te
dit rien parce qu' il peut y avoir quoi
vous pensez que les lettres anonymes
nous ne recevons pas on en reçoit tout
le temps alors voilà c'est quand même
une campagne sous tension c'est-à-dire
qui a mis cette tension et c'est la
question je voudrais ici
bah oui mais justement c'est c'est quand
vous regardez le déroulé il ya deux
phénomènes ya un phénomène qui est
gravissime c'est la volonté du pouvoir
actuel mais est ce que nous n'avons pas
fait la même chose que nous étions
pouvoir je n'en sais rien bien vous leur
avez revient vous savez et vous voulez
pas dire non je sais rien 1dans sert à
midi ça n'a pas été aussi franc et aussi
proche d'une élection présidentielle
encore que encore que je me souviens
qu'il ya eu des coups fourrés chirac
balladur en remontant même moins loin et
puis on sait très bien c'est fait
françois mitterrand c'est très bien si
elles font font les uns les autres je ne
pense que je pense que aussi nicolas
sarkozy n'a été blanc le dans ce domaine
là bon mais cela dit c'est pas parce que
les autres ont fait qu'on doit le
tolérer alors je sois là à partir du
moment où on a des preuves
la preuve elle n'a pas été loin mobile
entre 1 montrant un certain nombre de
dossiers en devient j'ai rien j'ai rien
j'ai rien quand on a dit on en a parlé
cette semaine puisque selon le canard
enchaîné il penserait déjà à reprendre
le leadership à droite en cas d'échec de
françois fillon d'amendements
législatifs fait est-ce que c'est
crédible selon vous c'est absolument
incrédible nom créé zhu était enfin
d'écouter pourquoi parce que il est
parti il s'est fait battre deux fois on
le veuille ou qu'on ne veuille pas qu'on
le regrette ou pas il a été battu en
2012 bien il avait dit qu'il ne se
représenterait pas il s'est représenté
pour le président du parti et se
présenter aux primaires il s'est fait
brûler le premier tour
et vous croyez qu'il va dire allez hop
une troisième fois jamais deux sans
trois alors qu'il a un boulot qu'il est
traduit en correctionnelle que j'espère
qu'il aura un non-lieu j'espère qu'il
aura rien ouais c'est pas simple et les
gens ne l'attend pas alors le problème
c'est qu'il faudra si nous gagnons nous
gagnons je l'espère je pense que nous
pouvons gagner mais nous faisons tout
pour françois fillon aujourd'hui il
n'est pas il faudra modifier changer
profondément les hommes et les femmes
c'est vrai que il faut un renouveau par
exemple qui pour incarner ce renouveau
on part de laurent wauquiez ce que ça
c'est peut-être parce qu'ils pourraient
être vous souhaitez pas leur en vouloir
waouw c'est pas tout à fait un homme
saoul mais c'est pas tout à fait ma
tasse de thé
pourquoi pas parce que je pense qu'il
est un peu excessif un peu bien moi je
suis un modéré je ne suis pas agressif
je suis un modéré j'aimerais bien qu'on
ait la possibilité
quoi qu'il arrive de réfléchir là où je
serai c'est à dire en dehors de la
politique
je le dis hein c'est vrai il faut
réfléchir à l'autre idéologie à nos
valeurs pour qu'on ait un corpus
idéologique pour pouvoir réunir autour
l'ajustement en dehors de la politique
vous venez d'en parler vous ne serez pas
candidat aux prochaines législatives qui
est qu'est ce que vous avez en tête est
ce que il ya une sorte de soulagement
vis-à-vis justement de tout ce qui se
passe en ce moment dans le monde
politique où est ce que vous allez
finalement regretter un peu maintenant
c'est en mettant les choses au point
j'ai une circonscription qui est en or
puisque quand on a voulu me se
présentait contre moi deux fois la
première fois j'ai même pas eu
l'investiture puisque c'est le rang
dominati qu'il ait vu j'ai fait rentrer
ses conditions pour cent des voix et là
deux fois en 2012 j'ai eu aussi 100 %
des voix pas mal est ce que vous vous
dites finalement c'est la fin d'un cycle
pour une génération comme la mienne et
je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui joue
alors la nage il faut à renault il faut
ce sera le cas cette conclusion pour
cette émission le renouveau car à très
bientôt travaux issus de programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires cha cha
[Musique]